medieval guilds could have been an
association of people doing any kind of
occupation there were even Guilds of
only teachers and Educators better known
today as universities medieval
universities like Oxford and Cambridge
functioned pretty much exactly as any
other medieval guilds did the guild I.E
the University was composed of Masters
who set the rules and laws for the guild
and who had apprentices for 4 years once
a student graduated he was a journeyman
also known as a Bachelor The Bachelor
could apply to the head of the guild the
chancellor of the university to be
appointed a master if you pass your test
you became a master in the University
therefore it is the medieval guilt
system from which we get our modern
ideas of a University degree and the
name for those degrees I.E a bachelor's
degree and a master's degree the idea of
a doctorate as something more than a
masters was a later development and did
not exist in the Middle Ages